je suis juste des enfants ce n'est pas
la police n'est pas devant un tribunal
un rôle c'est de protéger les enfants
dits en danger
bien taré ya problème la censure parce
que c'est un boulet pour tout le monde
ce dont tu vois ça fait franchement
quatre mois que tu mélanges de rouge
peut pas dire que ça passe très plaisir
de boire parlement va je parle trop
faible c'est dans les foyers qui la
prime ou victimes
quittons téléthon éducateur à partir de
jaude mans serait ce pas là je dis que
c'est une chance pour bien là on tourne
of rude alors pour la pétole et si pour
ton bien
ouanna secours
gens pour rien ça c'est à moi de le dire
je suis pas d'accord avec ça 6 me
sinon signalés ces derniers mois jugé au
mieux ses émotions d'accord avec ça est
ce que la reprise une scolarité vous
paraît vraiment pertinente
toi tout va bien et
je sais régler ses problèmes de violence
écoutons travail
je fatigue
souvent les murs sont d'une c'est lui
qui vont l'aider à y voir clair un âge
où on s'interroge
ce moment il va péter un câble en prison
vous j'ai confiance en toi
c'est quoi j'ai fait de mal
un contretemps me
c'est maintenant